welcome the oscar-winning star of the
accidental tourist Gina
a Russian czar once asked an artist how
did you carve such a remarkable likeness
of me out of that block of granite and
the sculptor replied I chipped away
everything that did not look like your
highness so it is with film editors they
received miles of film from a director
and then snip away everything that does
not look like the movie they're looking
for and here are the nominees for film
editing Martin Walsh for Chicago Thelma
Schoonmaker for gangs of New York
Peter Boyle for the hours
Michael Horton for the Lord of the Rings
the two towers
here vada loose for the pianist and the
Oscar goes to Martin Walsh for Chicago
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Martin wall
oh hi ooh a small corner of northern
England just when I'd like to thank Rob
Marshall for your vision thank you
Bill Condon for a fabulous script
Harvey Meryl Julie Jen everybody at
Miramax and my gang my own personal gang
of New York in New York that's another
little corner that just exploded and my
family my wife Beth my boys James and
max up there on the second tier where
are you yeah hi and have a great night
thanks a lot